le journal du dimanche a sollicité
pendant un mois les internautes pour
choisir les célébrités qui seront testés
dans le prochain top 50 des
personnalités préférées des français
cette phase de sélection a réuni plus de
huit mille votants 60 personnalités
étaient proposés et l'internaute
bourillon choisir que 15 avant de
découvrir le classement final vous a
fait un petit récap regarder qui rentre
dans ce pas ce mot comme chaque année le
journal du dimanche publiera fin
décembre le classement des 50
personnalités préférées des français
un sondage qui l'an dernier avait vu une
nouvelle fois triomphé jean jacques
goldman
cette année l'institut de sondage ifop à
tester de nouveaux noms de personnalités
pour savoir si elle était assez
populaire pour faire leur entrée dans la
liste des 68 noms proposés aux français
lors du sondage
24 nouveaux noms ont été retenus et
intègre le classement parmi eux nikos
aliagas soprano et cyril hanouna qui
fait son entrée avec 37 points 76 % des
suffrages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant travaux
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire c'est grâce aux internautes
et c'est grâce voilà au nom mais non pas
du tout c'est parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai une grosse communauté sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais ça ça veut rien dire du tout
pourquoi maintenant et pas avant ce que
votre notoriété elle n'est pas d'hier
dames 1 alors non j'avais déjà fait
partie du classement oui et il m'avait
sorti manu militari bas mais serena non
mais voilà et là c'est vrai que ça me
fait plaisir en tout cas de devenir
exercice à ne pas dire qu'on sera dans
les 50
mais voilà il ya des gens mal à moi je
suis moi j'aurais voté voilà pour
soprano ni coach aime beaucoup voilà oui
moi j'ai un boulot quand tu es sur notre
peau lui aussi j'ai pas compris le
fonctionnement quand même parce que
effectivement on vous à moi je vous ai
soutenu mais il fallait voter pour 14
autres personnes c'est ça ouais sauf que
dans les 14 autres personnes je n'ai pas
spécialement envie de voter pour des
gens on va vous leur direz a aucun temps
ci mais pourquoi mais déjà beaucoup pour
15 personnes qu'est ce que ça va est-ce
que ça compte pour vous c'est classement
où sont ses références à chaque rennais
ont le savoir qui en tête la trappe tout
vient d'y être on a une façon de vous
dire ce classement c'est toujours du
danger à goldman qui gagne à la fin
quand même un indicateur c'est une
tendance de l'air du temps de ce qui se
passe à l'instant t
donc pendant une période on a beaucoup
on a beaucoup vu des gens dont on parle
énormément à ce moment là
[Musique]
d
toujours pareil avec vos benhaim vous
avez tous les éléments pour tenir un
raisonnement cohérent et vous dites
n'importe quoi il suffit il suffit de
regarder le classement
c'est très bien que s'ils sont là mais
il ya un énorme problème dans ce
classement c'est quand même on dirait
qu'il a été commanditée par tf1 et
regarder dans les dix mille unités c'est
non mais là c'est parce que c'est ce
qu'on voit le plus si personne de
défense
c'est ce qu'on voit le plus le ballon